uh so uh summer more sentimental
keepsakes other on display resting can
you pass in that coaster it was my old
goldfish
hey townies welcome to another episode
of dumb people Town population news
population Carmel yeah
oh my God I'm so happy you're here I'm
so happy we get a chance to do this with
you you've been locked in a fantastic uh
writing job for years and years I know
we've been trying to do it for forever
and it was always like a Tuesday at 11
I'm like that I can't do it I'll be in a
writer's room at that time I'm gonna be
writing monologue jokes for James Corden
so that is so interesting and I will say
this you you told me you were just
starting to post stand-up clips and yeah
oh my god dude they're so good after
eight dollars after eight yeah
great mislead yeah yeah just don't um
and then they do stuff too the stuff yes
that we talked about the Catholic and
the Scientology so good thank you very
much that's all kind to me I just got
back from my honeymoon which I had to
push back several months and we went to
Italy yeah and I went to the Vatican
amazing and and Jesus came down from
from the ceiling I'm like I don't
believe in you he's like it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter here's 10
minutes of mediocre stand up
and Jesus said to Ian will you collab
with me yeah yeah also also great thing
is if he if he comes down and he's like
the [__] is all this you're like they
did this after you left he goes I'm a
Jew I don't wanna I don't need anything
have you done all this I don't need all
this it's too much yeah
I don't want to tell you guys how to run
your business yeah yeah have you done an
all fantasy everything uh God's deities
that's such a good idea that that has to
be all right we'll do it all right let's
do it we'll all do it we did Little
Debbie's night we'll talk about his
podcast because somebody got done
stories a bit about anti-Semitism being
the guy in the emergency room with the
sprained ankle is also a brilliant
what's weird is like a good event and
I'm getting people I'm getting other
Jews mad at me for like minimizing
antibiotism listen to me it still hurts
you said it still hurts
we posted and I'll say this we've talked
about this on other podcasts that we
were on but we posted a clip about uh in
Portland your city in your favorite City
we posted a clip about in from 2012 when
occupy the Occupy movie was there the
Tent City our bit was that an occupied
this part didn't make it you started
making it into the bid but the Occupy
Movement was a one-night stand that
lasted like an extra three years yeah
it's like once it should have been one
night would have been great the
concept's amazing I love what we're
protesting against this is actually
really great but then it went on too
long to where they're in these 10 cities
and they're become a society and they
need so if you want to be an anarchist
but then all of a sudden you find
yourself because of circumstance in a
society they start organizing it
actually so like you'd hear people you
walk through the society this is the bit
you hear people saying hey we need a
group of people to walk around and make
sure people aren't doing bad stuff to
other people you mean like cops no no no
no nobody said cop they're like hey if
uh Dave's got the herbal tea and Tina's
got the organic burritos and they want
to trade with each other because that's
the way we do it here uh what if he
doesn't have the tea you should just
write down on a piece of paper what it's
worth and then it'll be like money no no
money no money we do have to put those
slips in the central place where people
can be like a bank no
government
detailing the hypocrisy of anarchists in
a situation where they it's when you get
it over your skis it has nothing to do
with white ground left right yeah this
bit is taking off on our Instagram in a
way in right wing circles because they
think we are coming down on Communists
so now it's insane I'm like you guys are
going to understand whoever's following
us right now and God bless you for
following us you're gonna either under
we're either gonna teach you something
right or you're going to understand who
we are and they're going to unfollow us
right away but like you know we posted
this thing and it's like 300
000 views Insanity you have to just let
it so you just let it go you don't have
to let it go I don't read the comments
on Instagram or Tick Tock you just like
you put it out there and it's like Let
It Go God bless whatever you do with it
well it's it's you know there is just
it's it's funny and in some ways it's
dumb and it brings it right back to
where we are right now it's dumb people
town we have stories and I you did this
show before but the way we do it this
way we started doing it a new way and I
don't know if you guys have done your
podcast the same way the whole time but
like we each of us have a story so Jay's
going to start things off right now okay
uh my story Comes To Us by way of Liz
Hagerty at Liz Haggerty uh here is the
title and I I think this I don't think
this was in the uh Reddit section of
who's the am I am of the [__] but I
think this kind of plays out like that
okay bride wants a quote silent wedding
what silent wedding I've heard of Silent
birth is the bride Tom Cruise and ask
guests to whisper during reception her
her fiance says she's irrational this
can't last this relationship you can't
even get people to not bring their kids
yeah you can't even if you say hey no
okay we're trying to you're at least
getting three yeah yeah they are gonna
be loud they're not gonna respondent
weddings and if kids or not kids being
there whisper
so our friend Eva is a DJ and she just
DJ'd a silent disco which are the
greatest
headphones but if you ever roll up to a
silent disco and you don't have
headphones on it is no it's like those
clips where they take the music out of
the clip and they do and over it they
just put the sound of shuffling feet
over Mick Jagger it's hilarious it looks
like a massive stereo if you roll up on
it like what is happening right now all
right here we go so that's what she
wants her way to be and by the way can I
just say this before we even start yeah
like the groom how much did the groom of
this thing after she announces that this
is what it is went around to everyone it
was like see see what I have to deal
with as someone who just got married I
know you love your wife you guys have a
wonderful yeah I would say this guy you
don't have to deal with this no you
don't you should get out of them this is
the indication hopefully you guys are
peas in the pond
he's I mean I mean like he's kind of the
[__] and there's such a situation
wait does it we haven't even got it yet
this might just be the attendance he did
say to somebody in this article that
she's being irrational that's right so
like he is speaking out press about his
wife being arrested well doesn't he know
this doesn't get sprung on you it's not
like it's not like they're they like go
out and party and drink and have a great
time and are very close to their
families and then all of a sudden out of
the blue she's like it's going to be
sorry she's asked for dinners where we
don't talk yeah this has to be we don't
have the time to connect he's spoken
during succession and she gave him a
look that was like I'm gonna cut your
head up yeah well you got to pick your
spot yeah
uh weddings are meant to be a joyous and
raucous occasion surrounded by your
clothes memory friends as a rule as you
begin a new chapter in your life however
one woman wanted to wanted the complete
opposite for her big day according to
the Washington post's ask Amy advice
column oh okay she's good the woman
shared that she wanted to implement a
rather strange rule for a wedding my
fiance my fiance and I are planning our
wedding as the bride I'm planning on
making certain requests of my guests to
make sure that my special day is as
perfect as possible
it's chill out like yeah it's not just
your special day shut the f up it is a
special day for your whole family your
entire community and the people around
you that's what you learn when you're
like planning a wedding it is a little
bit about you a little also you're the
reason you're the reason but you're not
the whole like you're not the whole kind
of couldn't be less about you thank you
so many of the wonderful things at a
wedding and I got married just last
September you don't get to experience
well also also you got married a little
later in your life you're not getting
yeah you're not getting married it's
like a 22 year old you should tell
people I'm 38 because I think they're
see if they're seeing me on camera right
now they're like who's this young up and
coming that's right it's not 25 year old
why is there a 25 year old he also had a
he had a mustache for a while and you're
clean shave and you were looking younger
and younger by the moment so yes you you
wait a little bit this is a time but
again you're gonna have 40 I know it's
hard to cut you up if we have 45 minutes
at the end I will go over my skincare
routine lots of heels kills I've I've
ever sort of graduated you graduated
all right one of the requests quote
unquote the bride to me wants her guest
to follow is that they will have to wear
exclusively yellow at her ceremony
if she gets to determine who has sex
with him
this is she wants art she wants like we
don't speak
well it could be maybe oh yes I think it
is uh or she's like female Nexium cult
not a lot of people look good in yellow
that's a tough request very tough I saw
Steve Harvey in a yellow suit though and
I was like well that's Steve Harvey yeah
I mean I would like put him on a hand a
handless Segway now yeah yes period and
the yellow suit if you and just him
walking around spinning around with dead
eyes that's that's who's going to be
hosting at midnight Steve Harvey thank
you why yellow I don't know however
another request she wants all guests
attending around a wedding to follow is
to remain silent during the entire event
party too party too while the woman's
fiance has been supportive of all her
other requests he put his foot down on
having a silent and by the way he could
have just said her other requests he
said he said all all
you said I'm putting my foot down one
and two he didn't have to say anything
I've been Cooperative with her all of
her other regrets now if he just said
her other requests you're like okay but
all our other requests that word is a
heavy side that's the that's a choice
this woman goes in on her fiance to ask
Amy treating her like a therapist yeah
he angrily rejected my other request
that our guests remained silent
throughout both the ceremony and
reception let's say that's and reception
why do it do it are you ready here's
what she says to ensure that the focus
remains on us what you psycho crazy
person get out crazy this is the moment
at an improv group
somewhere else right
banana you can say apoplectic you can
say Majesty the tables for just do the
big gaudy head table yeah everybody
facing you
like there are a couple of moments here
I want everyone to be quiet but she
could have a couple of those moments no
no so then she says my fiance says that
this is irrational he does not want to
have a silent wedding thinking that
she's going to get support from this
yeah yeah can you believe this guy he's
saying he doesn't want to have a I mean
ladies back me up on this right while
the bride to be acknowledged that such a
thing is pretty quote unquote uncommon
she pointed out that silent weddings
have happened in her family before why
because people are like upset she'd
describe what goes into the planning and
executing a silent wedding which
consists of guests not being permitted
to speak and toasts only to be given by
mothers of the bride and groom
instrumental music will be playing
silently she said this is religion
instrumental how does instrumental music
played silently that's great hovering
over the strings yeah no you don't plug
into the amp wasn't that just
was that in a Woody Allen thing is
they're like playing in bananas no no it
wasn't in Woody Allen
the bride to be pointed out as the newly
married couple all the attention will
fall on them only but I know it's a lot
to ask or at least she acknowledged that
uh but I feel like I should have the
wedding I want
why the wedding you want well yeah or
don't have a letter very selfish so get
married to yourself have a celebration
for yourself that's silent go to do it
at a courthouse everybody yeah
so that the start of our life together
will be perfect well the rest of your
life is not gonna I mean if you cling to
this the rest your life is done I want
him to support me even if we disagree on
something how about you support him yeah
well that's the thing too like it's also
his wedding right right yeah
people that get to the wedding and
realize this might not work out blows my
mind yeah yeah I understand people
getting married and then in the course
of a marriage realizing oh this isn't
working getting a divorce but like you
get to just planning one event and you
write you realize how diametrically
opposed falls apart yeah was it hard
planning your wedding or no did were you
guys on the same page she I mean they
like my wife Dana did uh she did the
Lion's Share of the of the planning
which I know I mean like it's a cliche
but you guys lined up anyway we lined up
we lined up perfectly yeah
I had very few opinions she had she has
really good taste great I went I went to
everything I went to all the venues I
did the food you were active
participants I think that stuff's fun
though I went on the food tasting thing
of the desserts for my wedding and I was
like could you make a cake this I like
got so excited I'm like what if it was
chocolate on the outside yeah then on
the inside was like a sort of cream
vanilla cream and then in that is taught
like toffee bits like heath bars a heath
bar and the woman was like yeah I think
we could do that and they came back and
they said you know come back in two
weeks and we'll have that yeah they had
it we loved it she said by the way the
chef got excited to make this we're now
offering this at our wedding you came up
with a menu I have a menu item at this
time that's fun so that's fun that was
like a joy that wasn't mine I picked I
picked my spots at the wedding I like I
got like Voodoo Donuts so we had like so
good a huge table of Voodoo Donuts that
was good we I had like a special tea
blend made by this company in Portland
Smith tea which is great too yeah
the tea that everyone with a tote bag at
Powell Books drinks it kind of is it
really really if you stay in an Ace
Hotel it's like the tea at the age house
and I'm not even joking the tea that
people who are angry about the PDX
carpet changing drink yeah the people
who were mad at you for suggesting that
anything was wrong with our uh Occupy
Movement yeah they drink smooth tea all
right I love it so you picked your spots
I picked my spot and like the the music
thing was very important to me sure you
know like the thing having been to
weddings you start to pick up on like Oh
I like that I don't like that I like
that I want people to what was the best
thing I ever saw at a wedding yeah I
want to replicate that in some way with
my thing exactly yeah great yes well
this is not the best thing uh so in
response to the Future Brides advice
question or fiance's quote lack of
understanding I want to hear what Amy
has to say ask Amy colonist Amy Robinson
condemned the idea of a silent wedding
that's right Amy I hope your fiance is
paying attention because if you are this
self-centered now I can only imagine
what the dynamic will be later for
instance if you choose to have children
she pointed out she explained that
weddings aren't just for the bride but
our public events meant to bring family
and friends together I like a mass game
Amy Robinson Robinson added that the
bride's fiance doesn't have to support
her regardless of how good or bad her
tastes and ideas are if you don't want
Rowdy guests then limit or don't serve
alcohol she concluded wow which is also
a dumb idea but but I'd rather go to a
silent wedding
it's just a lot
hey can you shut up and drink vodka
tonics yes I can
[Music]
it's like everybody's like meet me out
in the alley yeah yeah yeah uh if you
want the the focus only and exclusive I
mean you then get married in a small
room standing before a mirror [__]
Amy will tell you if you're the [__]
lay in the wood uh that's it that's it
for this story but my goodness she's
dumb that is dumb I mean and she put it
definitely put it out there to this
woman because she's the one who wrote to
the woman thinking that she was going to
get all this she was like you know how
those like when that happens it was like
kind of like the uh someone was saying
like in the in the course of the writer
strike we're all striking right now that
like the young Executives who worked at
Amazon and whatnot like thought that
they were friends with the writers and
like that that that people would see
their side of things and then got the
rudest Awakening ever like no no you're
on the wrong side of this argument right
now I would have loved to have seen
those conversations happen in person
no no Randy and I have come on stage a
couple times and been like uh guys we
were supposed to do comedy tonight but
we are actually here to give you the
studio side of the strike now just hear
us out huge laugh and like we're like
look do you know how much money it takes
to keep a yacht up it takes
people don't consider how many times you
have to fly to the south of France thank
you check in on the yacht and you thank
you
my yacht can't be I can't take the 25
million extra I was going to pay for my
yacht and then give that to the people
to make the product at my thing better I
need that just for me and my wife how am
I supposed to live how am I supposed to
live is what our CEOs are saying and you
guys don't seem to understand that we've
been this we'll take five questions but
that joke is so dumb and it just goes to
show you how much like no one is
supporting that yeah but it's not a
single everybody within with the Netflix
Executives getting designed uh denied
their massive bonuses by their
shareholders you know it's like people
see it they're gonna see it this is
michiga break we come back we'll talk
about how you can support Ian uh follow
him on let's let's get his numbers up on
the old in IG and Tick Tock because he's
posting great stuff speaking of weddings
let's work on that engagement folks huh
yeah
hey there you go he's right here we'll
talk about his great podcast all fantasy
everything which is amazing right after
this it's dumb people down with Ian
Carmel don't go anywhere
hey guys welcome back to the show uh
before we get into all the great stuff
that Ian's got going on let's give a
quick shout out of stuff that we have
I'm not sure when exactly this is going
to drop but we'll lay some dates out for
you over the summer that are important
for us that we've got going on if you're
in Los Angeles uh I think this is
probably going to happen after June 14th
this will drop so July 19th July 19th
we're doing another tag it which we
should invite you should come and do I'm
in do you know the show you do your set
and Randy and I during your set the
whole time are writing tags I would love
to come on stage afterwards to you and
you take them away
this is lovely it's wonderful I love
that gift that keeps giving and so we do
that show we did it uh I think we're
gonna probably sell it on the 14th we're
doing the 19th and then we're going to
do it at Largo on uh on uh August 1st so
all that but the Big Show for us is at
Dynasty typewriter Jay and I have been
basically the last during this whole
strike and whatnot writing a Mike
Birbiglia style Neil Brennan blocks
yeah it's yeah it's basically the show
is basically we take an hour and a half
to make the case for being parents by
telling you how shitty parenting is it's
a heavy lift yeah and we kind of go
through our own story and this is it was
a big story on This American Life how at
six weeks old we may have been switched
I'm not this I'm just saying we're gonna
get into all of that it's our quest to
find out our own identity which is a
lifelong Quest that has taken up our
entire lives mixed in with our stand-up
bits about parenting mixed in with our
mom's story of her life and our own
lives and it's a really I we just
finished writing it and just did our
first video of it and July July 24th
which is a Monday night easy to go to in
the summertime Dynasty typewriter we're
doing two shows that one night obviously
want to sell out both of them it's going
to be a real indication as to hopefully
we can take it Off-Broadway potentially
doing in New York maybe do it out here
at the taper theater we have big plans
for this we love this idea and love this
thought it's the first time we've ever
really we did a show kind of like this
back when we got when we when I got
married back in 2001 we did it at the
HBO workspace yeah uh but this is the
first time in 22 years that we've done
something like that so very excited it's
not going to work out oh wow you don't
think so thank you for telling us now so
we don't waste time
it's like there's no way it's gonna
happen Ian said no and then we fought
you know what I mean
throw it in his face oh he's gonna be
there it's just like no alarms folded
the whole time who cares
why now
so that's going on and all that stuff
superscars.com you can get all the
tickets through that awesome Daniel I
know you're going on tour and yeah I got
dates that I'm announcing I'll be in
Chicago on August 19th I'm coming to Cap
City I'm doing High Plains Comedy
Festival I'll be in Boston I'm even
doing some dates in Europe so
everything's up at
danielvankirk.com also this knucklehead
said here was on your show which is like
really picky so it was so great yeah
this is before then the next one is July
10th at or I'm sorry July 11th at UCB
it's best bet comedy hosted by Irene two
and myself just nobody's coming to that
anymore see he's trying to I know he's
drawing up the anti uh at Best Bet
comedy on Instagram like overcoming and
then I like overcoming and people are
gonna hear this and they're gonna be
like well I'm gonna go yeah
uh and then join our patreon we have a
dumb people town patreon that is so much
fun in your stories we'll go over those
and we give you only five bucks yeah
it's really so good all right Ian uh
tell people about your fantastic podcast
which is just a dream to do uh it's
called My podcast is called how did this
get made
it's not your podcast [__] I love that
podcast though it's wonderful no my
podcast is called uh all fantasy
everything on all fantasy everything we
Fantasy Draft anything but Sports things
and although we've done Sports adjacent
things sure but like you name yeah uh
dvk was just on WE drafted action movie
stars with the you and Doug Benson which
was a lot of fun it was great you've
done it but I wasn't there you were
there we did Little Debbie snack cakes
which was what were the number one picks
on that uh Star Crunch was up there
she's up there Nutty bar was up there
yeah and uh it was really fun to go
through because to me I love the later
rounds yeah because you're really
digging into the barrel down those Swiss
cake rolls there was the other the one
we did a year ago was great we drafted a
diner oh my God that was a diner draft
was so did we have categories in that
one yes you had to do a side yeah an
entree a drink a dessert and then there
was like a wild card that couldn't be
food yeah
Flex it was aesthetic I took like an old
like a like an old waitress with a bad
attitude I think I took the pie case
yeah how about like an exposed rock wall
inside out
so what I leather boots what I love
about this is you don't have to be a
sports fan to enjoy this podcast because
but if you are a sports fan it's
remarkable because it follows the sort
of all the pathway of an actual draft
like a NFL or NBA draft but at the same
time so if you understand though there's
like jokes and layers of jokes for
things that people who would get that
thank you so that's
okay don't you agree that that's kind of
how it's set up I think so because you
have like yeah when we did action movie
stars look we you have a first round
running back that's not that sexy but
you have to take sure it was like Tom
Cruise right you know you have to take
it but what is that take this four foot
11 guy and lifts but I gotta take it
so good at it but then like in the in
the fifth round when you're taking like
Kurt Russell are you talking like you
get a steal you just get a big trouble
in China I'll take it yeah yeah so so
it's it really is a special show Jay and
I saw you guys do it live in uh right
before we did stand up in uh Minneapolis
sold out electrical fun and it's so fun
because you're like we don't know where
the comedy's gonna come from we just
know that we're gonna draft these things
and funny things will be said stories
will come out so I highly recommend you
guys if you I I feel like if you like
this spot this is what I kept thinking
as we were doing I'm like if you like
this it's a great adjacent like fun
thing that is like a griffy good time so
all fantasy everything what about all
your dates where should people go oh
yeah well we don't know when this is
coming out and my dates are all kind of
soon yeah is this going to come out in
the next week or two it could be in like
two weeks we're gonna be in Denver June
22nd 23rd and 24th okay good to know and
if this has come out already I did a
great job
I did really good uh no just check my
Instagram I have a website but it's uh I
know that's my next thing that I needed
outfits follow me on Instagram Tick Tock
Twitter all my daytime no with the K
Carmel with a K there you go do it are
you guys ready for a story let's do it
let's jump here we go from uh sign in
from we talking about practice at not a
game underscore three or three woman
what a great handle
Iverson lately though in that late in
that commercial is really bloated yeah
it was fun to catch up with them yeah
woman's man to catch up advertises for
Farmer to marry her best friend
so she wants a farmer to marry her and
she advertises for it I mean this is
what Farmers Only Farmers Only isn't
there also uh farmer wants a wife yeah
farmersonly.com is is the number one
farmer wants a wife is like a reality
show like our big big love from the big
city yeah well that's what this is she
don't understand a New Zealand woman
named Liv K probably live slash pgak I
can't believe she merged with the PGA
that was actually a big surprise yeah he
wants to find a farmer to wife up her
best friend wife up when she met farmer
Ali K same name obviously different she
left the Big Smoke of Auckland New
Zealand for the Rolling Hills of King
country and hasn't looked back since by
the way just tell you I've been to
Auckland it's a lovely city it's not a
big Smoke City and the the Farms along
the countryside of New Zealand are just
quaint and beautiful yeah like hobbiton
right yeah can I say this that Ali K is
my favorite Sasha Baron cone character
he plays dumb as a farmer and then he
gets oh he sets up Trump with his with
his uh ice cream sauce while she loves
the farm lifestyle in waitomo I tried
one thing is missing her best friend
Amber oh man Amber I've missed my friend
heaps it was the only thing I struggled
with about moving to the farm I've
always joked about them moving down here
too Kay tells the New Zealand Herald you
need a farmer to make that happen
reframe heaps he originally found a
picture
heaps originally from Terra Knox which
is actually on apps
I don't know when she was 12 years old
where she met Amber at a pony Club brag
that's a plus no we get it you rode Pony
the girls are inseparable ever since
until Kay met and married Ali in a
unique love story of her own I pretty
much moved in on the second date
Jesus Christ and I never left they got
married this year Amber was a bridesmaid
now cut to him telling his farmer
friends I couldn't get rid of him second
date I was stuck with I think we're
married I think it's the schlep if
you're going after the farm right you
know you got to make that decision quick
so Liv has taken it upon herself to find
a farmer to marry Amber and move her out
of the city that's right it started as a
joke but you never know what can happen
I rang her and I was laughing
and I said thoughts on me writing an ad
for you I just think farmers are so
great there's so many amazing guys in
rural communities I'm always joking with
friends that they need to find a farmer
as a person born on a farm raised
working on farms we're not just like
interchangeable cans of things at
Walmart they're all the same it's not
you can't every school get yourself a
farmer yeah like and she's like oh
perfect because I like Farmers right you
should like them you like them too yeah
this should inform your life Amber
tracked up and said go for it oh shut up
here's the ad I can't wait to hear it I
have a great offering for the New
Zealand farming Community we're talking
about a person yeah which the New
Zealand farming Community is going to be
like subsidies for half our problems
exactly no it's no I'm creeping I'm
pimping my best friend out a master a
mass buy of soybean from the Chinese
market
ideally this would happen in King
country in the king country region oh
now she's calling her region I met and
married a farmer two years ago oh who
cares about you in this area is
inserting or inserting her own story
were people talking at their wedding
yeah
well the goats were making noise she
says I left the Big Smoke of Auckland to
embrace the farming lifestyle in mighty
king country whilst good use good use of
wild in an ad yeah well it's been great
there's one thing missing my best mate
Amber after countless hours of
brainstorming on how I can improve this
aspect of my life I've come to the
conclusion I need to find her an
eligible farmer from the mighty wakato
this is the point where in is at the
show and he's like who cares
goodbye to the city and join me in my
journey into learning all about the
farming lifestyle so here's it goes
here's a bit about Amber would you guys
like to guess her age uh sure
um live and her are best friends
29 31 38 27 years old wow she's 27 an
absolute drop dead looker very great and
super down to earth who's not afraid to
get her hands dirty there you go she
grew up with horses she can set up
fences clean troughs
troughs and she's always she always
Cooks a mean Curry I look I mean farmer
doesn't like a good curry am I right
famously right I'll take a friend who
can yeah maybe yeah it sounds amazing by
the way after spending her childhood
caring for Animals she decided to take a
step further and formally study Animal
Health becoming a surgical vet nurse
okay buried
oh you did finally watch Barry okay good
buried not bury the series the 1982
Alpine Valley Avalanche yeah
here's a dumb person the person who like
who's got cabin fever with her boyfriend
decided to walk up towards the thing
don't don't say anything else is that
documentary yeah yeah yeah
1982 Alpine Valley uh amazing footage I
watched the volcano one that was in New
Zealand or whatever yeah oh my God I
gotta watch that one yeah of like their
withered arms oh God that's brutal
brutal hey here's an idea um don't hang
out around an active volcano go to an
active volcano just stay on the boat
you're close enough volcanoes are fine
until they're not until they're not
that's right and there's not like a
warning it's like Farmers you know what
it is it's like Amber she's fine until
she isn't Amber sounds like she should
already be the one on the farm she's a
surgical Fitness how is Amber not like
unless she just doesn't want to be with
anybody she sounds like an unbelievable
person it has her own thing going on
it's a Veterinary surgeon great job
making Curry that's right all things
great and small creatures this is Amber
gorgeous come on
come on lady she's less attractive than
my wife but she's very pretty she's not
as attractive as Ian's wife she's looks
like Denise Richards yeah she then
transitioned into pet nutrition industry
so not only does she have a great Animal
Health knowledge she can also get you a
discount on quality dog biscuits what an
Ashley fantastic I wonder if she's a big
fan of Maeve thank you shout out to me
Amber doesn't take life too seriously
loves loves a good laugh now this is
where you lost me yeah who doesn't yeah
if I'm laughing I'm fine if you guys are
quiet I will laugh Amber's the most kind
and Beautiful Soul you've ever met she's
actually so nice she agreed to let her
desperate best mate who misses her so
much embark on a journey to get her to
join me she's a great helper when
visiting the farm from running the dogs
to offering to help with prolapsed use
there's nothing this girl won't do she's
a big girl standing just under six foot
tall she's a big girl it's I'd be like
nothing wrong with that but like let's
be more specific about it she's a big
girl anyway
standing under just six feet tall she
doesn't feel like a giant she does
prefer a man with height fair enough
people like me or farmers get him out of
here if there's someone out there who
thinks they could offer my drop dead
gorgy absolute Legend of a best mate
please get in touch with me I'll be
screening applicants and setting up
interviews for the position meanwhile
her husband's like can you help me
outside yeah please we're on a phone I'm
getting all kinds of information you
have chores in this relationship she
also comes with her own border collie uh
who doesn't have a clue about stock but
stays out of the way and is very cute
please message me a little bit about
yourself if you're interested thank you
and then she's like should I put she's
into anal like just at the end just in
the very very end just that simple it's
okay guys yeah I mean whatever it's good
herpes have been dormant for 20 years it
wasn't long before countless messages
started rolling in for men all over the
country and Katie started screening all
the potential dates great again you have
chores to do on this in this throughout
the process Amber also you don't need a
man to move you don't need a woman to
move it you don't need anybody other
than your own interests to do and reason
to move anywhere right the worst
reasonable anywhere right also the fact
that this woman is going through these
Great Lengths they get her friend out
there is not a great endorsement for
living on a farm if you're not actively
performing it's like I'm so bored that
she's trying to she's lonely
relationship
this life yeah the only thing that's
going to save me for it is if my mate
comes out here it's misery loves company
defined it turns out Amber has been on a
few dates with someone K reveals that
it's going well and she's currently not
taking any more applications okay
good to know duly noted so two dates in
so she's moved in by this yeah yeah why
haven't you moved in Kay thinks she's
destined to a rural lifestyle she needs
she'd need a reason to live close to me
and my husband how about just volition
your own yeah
um I would be really stressed if I got
her to move out to the country and she
didn't like it that's all on her friend
she's got her own thing going on I can
definitely see her moving rarely she's
super independent and she's got this
really good career but she can work
remotely a career that you don't know
that she can continue you got to see all
creatures
okay says there's something of a rural
urban divide when it comes to dating and
hopes the post will change people's
perception of farmers you didn't talk
about farmers at all other than just
being a thing you can acquire if you'd
like one right come on that's it you get
a farmer you get a farmer it's like
Oprah if any of our townies ever hear an
update on this if she marries a farmer
let us know and I'll rescind but I don't
think this is the way her life's gonna
go otherwise it would already it was
right also her name's Amber yeah that's
a city name
I mean that's that's something that's an
alert if I've ever sent out an amber
alert
uh rand's gonna have Story number three
I saw the word rug that's all I know
maybe that's enough of a hint right
there you give us a preview Rand can you
let us know yeah you know as somebody I
don't know for all the pets out there
this is a way to keep your pet around
forever we'll get to that on the other
side of the break some people town with
the in Carmel don't go nowhere which
means go everywhere but don't go and
actually stay where you are
hey guys welcome back to the show Ian
Carmel is with us I'm gonna take us home
with that yeah all right this is sent in
by uh Liz Haggerty who also sent in a
earlier Story one of our stringers
fantastic uh the story is from October
of uh 2022 it appeared as a link in
another story that Liz sent so I'm gonna
give her the assistant
sometimes in the dumb stories Ian
they'll be like if you like this you're
reading this you might also like this
yes
with all fantasy everything yeah yeah
right exactly yeah and all fantasy and
everything with us I mean that was a
great joke by the way that you and I saw
Michelle wolf we got to give a shout out
to her earlier about uh
uh Jeff bezos's wife is was like listen
on the Forbes list I mean the whole bit
that she did was really funny about
listen on the Forbes list that she had
60 million dollars she's like 60 60
billion dollars
so she's like you didn't have 60 billion
dollars uh Jeff Bezos had a 120 billion
dollars last year it's like his
excellent that was such a good joke it's
like and then she lists herself as a
writer as an author author you didn't
make 60 billion dollars as an author you
just happened to be like in your husband
was like the owns the largest bookstore
in the world and they can get Annie you
can promote whatever so just put
philanthropists
what a huge philanthropy joke about you
you can put whatever you want to like
help promote the through Amazon it's
like you bought trash liners you might
also like this garbage great yeah great
joke all right thank you I took took
this and then I moved over right uh
Aussie family turns pet dog into
ornamental rug what is going on they're
taking a lot of licks over in Oceania
yes so I don't I don't like this at all
we just like your dog just lost our dog
we just lost our 12 and a half years
oh will you go wipe your feet on our
beloved family just go is it a bath what
if you get another dog so we have we
have now a new imagine the smell who I
brought here what and the puppy has
definitely taken a [__] on the rugs yeah
what if your new puppy takes a [__] on
the old dog rug can you imagine maybe
it's just the bubble we live in although
I spend a lot of time in Rochelle
Illinois sure anybody's house that I
walked into that had any animal as a rug
and they're not Teddy Roosevelt yes I
would be like what is your why are we
still doing I don't want to stand on the
whole rest of your life has to play into
having an animal rug everything
are you imagining it's the dog splayed
out with his head and yeah with a ball
in it what else would it be
a grieving Aussie family who lost their
beloved pet has found a way to preserve
the dog forever take a [__] photo but
not everyone is fond of this interesting
Keepsake also shut up and let these
people do what they want now if you put
it outside the front door and it says go
away on it that is gonna deter people
this could happen to you yeah yeah
solicitors yeah
melbourne-based company Chimera
Taxidermy shared a video on social media
review revealing how the skin and fur of
a golden retriever has been preserved so
it can be honestly in the family's home
oh this is a plot line in Silence of the
lamps is it beautiful old yeah
beautiful old golden retriever preserved
as Pelt it puts the Alpo in the basket
in the comments she explained that the
Pelt has been tanned and turned to
leather so that the fur won't fall out
meaning it'll remain good in good
condition for years to come I'm going to
show you a picture of this again
oh no
really I don't understand it looks like
his entire body got sucked out yeah it's
bones and every all the inside's got the
sunshine like it's soft do you know how
we lost the dog well I've got more
nightmares for you yeah it's gonna get
worse sit down sit down on the old dead
dog and I'll tell you what happened
let's watch Raiders of the Lost Ark and
then you'll understand what happens
basically it was a Nazi dog that saw the
ark this is like the Total Recall what
were you gonna ask just remember stuff
just remember yes remember the dog you
had also you know what what also
benefits us as humans yeah I just read a
thing about this this a woman suffers
from that condition where she remembers
everything all the time right oh yeah
yeah and so her husband passed away and
people were like how amazing you can
you'll you'll remember so many she goes
it's the worst thing in the world yeah
every day I can remember as though he
died this morning oh my God other guys
humans forgetting is part of our
grieving process you don't want to
remember everything like it's fresh and
new because it's so hard to get distance
from it and fill that space with new
memories you don't like just forget
about the dog on some level right don't
forget you had it but like you'll just
have your six pristine beautiful
memories of it and then everything else
will fade away get a skylight frame
rotate some pictures without doing fun
things thank you so the approach
received mixed responses from people
online and while some people I can't
believe it's even mixed so we loved it
who loved loved decorator psycho loved
it
so someone said this is interesting but
certainly not for everyone that's the
under that's the kindest way to put that
yeah my memories give me peace I
couldn't do this it would make it harder
for me wrote another there you go yeah
the third said while the idea is sweet
and could be good for the right person
no that is really not sweet the right
serial killer hiding out Mouse race
you're all back in the dating uh pool or
you went back in time to the dating pool
you go to somebody's house and they have
a pelt of their doll no I run instant I
am instant make an excuse I feel
I would say the way we grieve and
process and deal with things I can't do
we're just not gonna yes you're next
that's all I would think you're next
I remember you Ian oh and you could be a
Batman
I see it I will make this noise
and then I am gone uh speaking with
Yahoo news Australia Maddie who is based
on the Mornington police Peninsula
agreed that it's definitely not for
everyone and she said ABS she absolutely
respects that PEX pet Taxidermy has only
really become more popular in the last
how many years or so if you think it's
gotten it's a growth industry uh pet
taxes has only gotten popular in the
last how many years or so six what do
you think twelve you said 15. okay one
of you is one year off from what they're
saying eleven five
yeah that feels strong uh but I'll go uh
I'll go 16.
get your answers in town is because five
years or so so it's a very new things
the real pet tax under my heads no it's
only really right yeah I was on to it in
93.
yeah I mean it's gotten really
mainstream yeah uh so uh some are more
sentimental keepsakes other on display
resting can you pass through that
coaster it was my old goldfish
resting yeah get the Dr oh no come on
the gerbil all right the dog's playing
with the drug uh resting on their beds
or however they're on there there's one
of them preserved most of the requests I
get are for full Taxidermy amounts Pelt
preservation is less commonly asked for
but I still do quite a few pelts so I
think it is becoming more and more
popular I can't we will close on this
how much how much does it cost to get
your pet turned into a pelt rug
depending on the size of the dog of
course you'll just we'll just ballpark
it what do you think it is
twelve hundred dollars twelve hundred
thirty five hundred dollars Jay what do
you think
18.50 okay
get your answers in town what town is
what what a wonderful episode with the
great one on Carmel follow him on Tech
talk follow him on Twitter go listen to
our episodes as your way into all
fantasy everything and you will check
all fantasy everything everywhere all at
once that's what I want to do that like
characters and everything everywhere all
at once different all the family all
fantasy everything
realities of that movie
oh that would be amazing you could pick
reality the hot dog finger reality you
just come up with new ones yeah that's
good yeah yeah so it's a theme yeah the
giant swirling everything everybody's
got piano just locations locations all
fantasy everything is the name of the
podcast subscribe to that listen to that
and uh I will tell you get your answers
in townies that uh getting your dog
turned into a pelt for just average
ballpark rugging up your dog rugging up
your dog 700 bucks
okay that's also an indication you
shouldn't be doing yeah absolutely yeah
it's too cheap it's like when the guy
it's like when like we were getting our
hair it's almost like a like a gas price
we got our hair cut in New York and it
was 10 bucks in 1994 and like West 4th
Street and then we showed up one day and
it was seven and we got mad
you're on the border of not giving a
[__] now like it's down to seven now we
can't complain about any
you want to be able to complain a little
bit I might take it up to 11. all right
there you go guys that's the show we
love you guys so much thanks for uh
joining us in dumb people Town join our
patreon and uh oh [__] nobody's gonna
join you yes
and oh [__] we gotta get back to work
town
[Music]